so according to Beals is obituaries in
the New York Times from 1942 she
acquired this camera as a result of it
being a subscription prize from
children's magazine that was published
in Boston and this kind of camera was
relatively inexpensive this small box
camera essentially a hole in a box with
perhaps a lens I have an examine it
closely enough to know but the lights
passing through the hole and projecting
itself onto some kind of film on the
back of the camera to have fallen in
love with photography through this
device means you love the elemental
magic of photography this is not one of
our brilliant muralists digital cameras
of today this is a very basic apparatus
but at this moment a few things are
happening at photography of particular
relevance to her life things that are
happening that she took advantage of in
an extraordinary way and one has to do
with the size of the camera the fact
that it's shrunk down from these large
boxes that were used previously into
this small handheld device for most of
the middle of the 19th century cameras
were large boxes quite heavy on tripods
they took a lot to lug around but
beginning in the late 1880s we have the
introduction of these small cameras most
famously from Kodak in 1888 although
there were a number of companies
producing these small cameras they were
handheld they were much less conspicuous
they allowed the photographer to be
mobile to move around to take
photographs of people sometimes when the
people were not aware that they were
being photographed for this reason they
were often called detective cameras and
a lot of ethical questions were raised
about whether or not photographers had
become a little too inconspicuous but
they also afforded opportunities to
capture
modern life on the fly so photographers
now could walk around and snap pictures
of things that were just unfolding on
the street in a way that photographers
of earlier generations couldn't do a key
technological development for Beals was
the advent of halftone technology for
reproducing photographs in print for the
early decades of photography there was
no easy way to turn a photograph into an
illustration for a newspaper because it
had to be converted basically to a wood
engraving which was a technology that
predated photography so no labour was
saved you were just using the photograph
as the model rather than a scene in real
life with halftone technology a screen
was used to photo mechanically reproduce
the photograph in print and this gets
perfected in the 1890s more or less so
right around the time that Beals is
starting to think perhaps of becoming a
photojournalist so she's getting in on
the ground floor this is really a new
occupation an occupation that didn't
really exist prior to these
technological developments so it's
rather extraordinary that she managed to
find herself in this occupation by dint
of her effort and initiative one thing
we tend to forget today is the extent to
which these small cameras were
associated with the emergence of the
bicycle which comes out at around the
same time the safety bike comes out in
the early 1890s absolute revolution some
people call it a fad but they're not
far-seeing enough the bike is is a
tremendous revolution it's followed so
quickly by the automobile that looking
backward we just focus on Henry Ford and
the emergence of the automobile but the
emergence of the bike when it happened
was huge
I mean susan b anthony said it did more
to liberate women than anything else in
this notion that the world was becoming
more mobile more accelerated and that
this offered opportunities for
liberation is
something very important to remember it
was unsettling people were worried that
the world was becoming too fast that it
was somehow becoming unreal
but I think for enterprising women this
was a time of great opportunity
you